now it's time to settle down and enjoy
some slow-cooked favorites what are the
brilliant things about slow cooking is
there's often very little preparation
required and it's the oven that does all
the work my first recipe is packed with
strong confident flavors and with the
oven taken the strain is a pleasure to
make delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast one of the secrets that the slow
cooking is to be robust and really get
stuck in big bold flavors worked
brilliantly well so don't be precious
this is gutsy cooking at its absolute
best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cuts and it's sort of tucked alongside
the rib they're being boned out the skin
has been taken off I'm gonna roll them
stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
season season them both sides inside and
out really important doesn't look like a
real weighty dense cup of meat but once
his beautifully slow braise it's just
like melting lamb it's incredible
on a season that rests with some dried
oregano
put a heat in there some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest just amazing salted anchovies
in there
they almost melts inside of a lamb so
the balance of flavors work beautifully
now pull it down toward you and roll
that nice and tightly so I'm looking for
strength just need to tie them three
times one at each end and one in the
middle I fell in love with this dish
years ago when I first started working
in Paris because we had all the lamb in
from the Pyrenees nice thing is they
could be done the day before pan on
olive oil in get that oil nice and hot
lamb in really important to you it's a
nice color on there whilst they're
browning slice the onion but I was gonna
be cooking for two nine hours
so don't slice the onions too thinly
otherwise they'll burn garlic and leave
whole I've got a color on them that
beautiful take them out onions in and
garlic straight in love it that's a
secret about slow braising you never
change pans why all the goodness isn't
that one pan do chili seeds in there are
gana nice pinch
little bit of lemon in there and I do
the onions what I did to the lamb next
my capers
fire them off get them exploding to
bottle the pan they get nice and crisp
in next my black olives now white wine
bring that to the boil deglazing the pan
as well rinsing the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now rare that tomatoes
[Music]
puncher those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice lid on into the oven 172 two
and a half hours and forget about it
well beautiful all that was reduced down
as amazing nice tomato sauce and the
lamb has kept his color braised
beautifully very carefully little bits
there slice off pull off the little bits
of string this is why I get really
excited the secret is not to slice it
too thinly and smell the lemon
hard to believe when you slice through
the center there but that is a very
cheap cut of meat I'm celebrating I love
this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions I'm amazing rich for horse
take your lamp sort of just sit it on it
looks incredible that for me is why
chefs get so excited with cheap cuts
because the end results are incredible
delicious breasts of lamb with lemon and
Chavez chili and Ariana
[Music]
slow cooking is a fantastic way to
develop delicious deep flavors here are
three of my easy one-pot wonders minimum
preparation long cook and an amazing
wonderful taste first up easy bolito me
stow a classic Italian mix me dish
I'm starting with some Italian fennel
sausages fire them until colors making
sure all sides are nicely browned
set them aside then slice treat so a
spicy Spanish sausage with a wonderful
smoky taste and fry so releases all this
incredible flavor next chopped carrots
celery garlic and add to the same pan
this keeps in all the flavor stir into
pre lentils these are excellent for
slow-cooked dishes because they retain
their firm texture and shape next add a
bay leaf and some fresh thyme sprigs
then the sausages go back in along with
chicken stock
simmer until the lentils are tender then
season to taste finally sprinkle with
chopped parsley and serve simple to
prepare a cinch to make and pack full of
delicious hearty flavors my twist on an
Italian classic Magnificent easy bleat
oh mister
[Music]
my next everyday effortless dish is
slow-cooked aubergine dice the aubergine
and fry in hot olive oil until colors
and all sides then add a finely sliced
onion and chopped garlic cook until
tender add cooked butter beans and
pomegranate molasses which is a sweet
thick and glossy tankey reduction of
pomegranate juice season next add a can
of chopped tomatoes bring to a simmer
and cook until the aubergine has a
gloriously soft and silky texture stir
through chopped mint pile onto toasted
bread and finally for a lovely salty
tang crumble over some creamy feta
cheese
minimum preparation but slow-cooked for
maximum flavor aubergine like you've
never tasted before one more dish that
uses time to transform a humble
ingredient is perfect slow-cooked beef
[Music]
start by finding the beach in in hot oil
seasoning as you go
this is a very economical cup of beef as
it slow cooks it also makes the most
delicious gravy as the mayor of thickens
and flavors of source
[Music]
in the same pan so they chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots sliced celery
peeled and chopped ginger and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
[Music]
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine and the juice of
an orange this de glazes the pan adding
incredible depth of flavor
[Music]
pouring chicken stock season and simmer
for an hour and 20 minutes
this dish is brilliant finish with
gremolata a dry Italian salsa made with
chopped herbs simply chopped parsley and
garlic together a mix in the zest of an
orange or lemon when the beef is cooked
rich unctuous and beauti tender scatter
over the lovely fresh gremolata simple
satisfied and crammed full of wonderful
tastes and textures delicious fast to
prepare cheap and easy to make
slow-cooked to perfection three amazing
dishes I guarantee you'll make time and
time again this is my essential guide to
kitchen equipment everything you need to
know about the basic kit that will get
you cooking fantastic food casserole
dish absolutely essential when it comes
to good home cooking why so versatile
the beauty of this thing is the fact
that you can actually use it on the hob
or start it on the hob and finish in the
oven more importantly cast-iron it
conducts the heat so you can have the
gas on absolute minimal well the oven
down to its absolute lowest setting and
the thing will just cook naturally
casserole dishes are surprisingly
versatile and a great investment
you only need one and if you look after
it will last you a lifetime brilliance
for one-pot wonders one of the biggest
bills in the kitchen is gonna be from
meat so it's crucial you keep cost down
but that doesn't mean sacrificing flavor
especially when you use some slow
cooking magic to get the best from cheap
cuts to get value for money it always
pays to ask an expert and fifth
generation award-winning master butcher
Danny Lydgate is a man in the know
things about going to a purchase they
can have more cuts available than most
supermarkets so you're gonna see things
that people don't know about so one
example might be the beef ribs are great
product a slow cookie in the oven but
you're cooking on the bone you're going
to get more flavors from the bone
there's some really nice pieces of juicy
meats he's only used for mints in the
past now people are using it for
braising or slow braising or even
barbecuing it there's some really nice
marinades the oxtail are less popular
now than maybe they used to be small
little muscles make up a tail whilst
that slope
they all fall apart really tender juicy
meat also oxtail is sublime in stews
curries and soups
another great cheap cut for slow cooking
is one you saw me using earlier lambs
breast it's one of the least expensive
cuts of lamb and it's also delicious
slow roasted or stewed here we have the
shin of beef where you can see in the
shins made up of lots of little
different muscles these are always
moving always doing work so slow cooking
will give the best end results
it's gone our fashion a little bit but
it should be enjoyed by everybody it's a
fantastic piece of meat here we have
some ox cheeks and when they're trimmed
doing that with a really lean piece of
meat obviously with the cheap cows
always eating munching on grass this
means I need a lot of cooking but
essentially it's a really nice healthy
lean piece of meat with fantastic
flavors ox cheek also make an incredible
ravioli or regu and if your pork liver
why not try pork neck is a succulent
alternative for a slow Sunday roast here
we have a muscle from the shoulders
called feather blades the reasons called
feather blade is because when it's cut
each piece looks like a feather the
gristle tends to be slow cooked and the
more it's cooked alternative latinus
giving a lovely jelly in juicy liquid to
the meats fantastic for casserole in
pies and stews there are so many cheaper
cuts which are brilliant for home
cooking
it's important with all these forgotten
cuts to find out how to cook them don't
be scared of them a really economic full
of flavor and the end result is
fantastic meal
as a chef one of the biggest kicks I get
is taking an ingredient that doesn't
cost much and turning into something
that looks and tastes like a million
bucks my next recipe turns what used to
be a decidedly unfashionable cut of meat
into the star of the dish fit to grace
any table slow roasted pork belly with
fennel slow roasting works better on
fattier tougher and unfashionable cuts
whether it's a cheek or even a neck or
this amazing pork belly it's a fantastic
way to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection take a very sharp
knife bring the pork belly towards you
so you're over it you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife I'm just sort of nicking it they
go across the pork belly long strokes
with a knife
take your time turn it 180 this time
what we're doing is just sort of cutting
it was nice little sort of diamonds but
as that starts roasting on top it starts
getting nice and crispy take handfuls of
salt and just sort of rub it in bend it
over in in those cracks really helps to
get a nice crisp crackling on top
roasting tray getting really nice and
hot take a whole / fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meek succulent
and braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables crush and
peel three whole cloves of garlic and
add to the fennel olive oil in fennel in
I like the nice strong aniseed flavor
they go to that nice rich dense poor
fennel seeds delicious star a nice in
just a couple of - cardamom seeds Wow
they're like little bangers like little
firecrackers incredible lovely fresh bay
leaves get your pork skin side down just
sear the top of that fat that locks in
all that amazing flavor then I'm gonna
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then one fennel seeds embed it in
those little cracks now some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that
behind you can you smell that
lights fragrance and with fennel
I'll have the wine to bubble away and
reduce until the alcohol has burnt off
I've got the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that means under there but we
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything and
the stock reduces and braises at the
same time really importantly bring that
back up to the ball before it goes in
the oven otherwise it'll never boil
never get up to temperature it smells
incredible slow roasted pork belly at
180 degrees for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you got that nice crispy
skin on top you can see how much for the
stock has evaporated about onto the
board it looks stunning to make a
delicious rustic sauce with the flavor
packed contents of the roasting tray
first get rid of the excess fat take a
couple of slices to press it's like a
perfect sponge because you just lay that
on top drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that fat if you want
the perfect fry bread trust me stick
that in a fine pan a nice teaspoon of
mustard whisk that in and then simply
simmer for a few minutes before pouring
into a serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife you can hear that
that is amazing incredibly tender that
belly of pork is gonna almost melt in
your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy belly of pork what an
amazing way to cook a very cheap cut of
meat
[Music]
next my tricks the trait and kitchen
tips
first how to make a fantastic chicken
stock a classic slow-cooked recipe that
gets amazing flavor from simple
ingredients chicken stock the vital
ingredient to good cooking it transforms
sources is the fantastic base for soups
and more importantly it's so easy to do
a little bit of love and care at the
beginning and it cooks itself right step
1
chicken carcass into a pie psy.d pan and
onion doesn't even be finely chopped the
vegetables flavor the stock onion in
then from there
cut your leek it's a nice big solid
chunk roughly same size as the onion so
with vegetables cook at the same time
and then a carrot celery in garlic and
then a nice sprig of thyme that helps to
really give depth of flavor to the
chicken stock a couple of bay leaves and
some fresh parsley and then peppercorns
pan and just lightly crush them and a
little pinch of salt and now just cover
the vegetables and the carcass with cold
water just cover the chicken and the
vegetables bring it up to the ball as
quick as you can
now as it comes to the boil a really
nice skin take the base of a ladle and
swirl that around that pushes all the
grease and the impurities to the side of
the pan then get your Laden and just
tilt it if you don't skim all that off
and the stock becomes very cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
then it needs to cook for 3-4 hours at a
time
this is one chicken carcass let that
boil away gently for 30 to 40 minutes
maximum
now we're gonna pass it off take a sieve
place that over the pan and then just
pour that in it smells amazing
it's aromatic the color absolutely
beautiful and there you have the most
amazing stock when you need to season
meat in flour a great tip is to place it
in a plastic bag to dust it evenly using
flour also helps the sauce to get nice
and thick during cooking
we're browning meat fry in small batches
don't crowd the pan otherwise it won't
sear or color properly when slow
roasting meat
line the bottom of the roasting tray
with chunky vegetables like onions
fennel and carrots they act as a trivet
to keep the meat from boiling in his own
juices plus the bed can be the base for
your gravy later on after slow cooking
baked-on residue can be tough to remove
but if you bought water in the pan it
will dissolve and break down then simply
pour out and wash with soap and water
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking